la situation en afghanistan continue
d'en parler avec notre invité régis le
sommier journalistes il est en direct
avec nous bonjour merci d'être en direct
sur rt fonce alors si on revient sur la
phrase du ministre de l'intérieur un
transfert pacifique du pouvoir vers un
gouvernement de transition ça veut dire
que ça y est le gouvernement donne le
pouvoir aux talibans en quelques sorte
oui et je crois que gouvernement d'un
premier choix puisque son armée
n'a pas combattu toutes les toutes les
villes sont tombées les unes après les
autres sont véritablement qui les deux
d'afrique n'ont donc n'ayant ayant
choisi de ne pas défendre car ils n'ont
plus le gouvernement n'a pas d'autre
choix que de céder le pouvoir aux
teintes blanc qu'on appelle gouvernement
de transition on imagine que ça va être
évidemment piloté par les talibans voilà
alors impossible de parler de
l'afghanistan sans parler de
l'intervention des américains ont les
américains qui partent après être restés
dans le pays pendant 20 ans et en
quelques mois à peine les talibans
prennent le pouvoir la question n'est
pas de savoir pourquoi les américains
sont partis s'ils sont partis trop vite
mais pourquoi et qu'est ce qu'elles ont
fait pendant vingt ans de présence en
afghanistan
c'est sûr que ya eu plusieurs îles
plusieurs messages en fait à plusieurs
époques plusieurs 20 ans c'est très long
on a pendant longtemps
le vrai fan les etats-unis ont pendant
longtemps oeuvré à la construction d'une
nation et puis il ya eu une augmentation
de 2 de l'effectif des troupes
américaines qui ont été quand même
jusqu'à 100000 ya quand même eu 800
mille hommes en afghanistan et puis
ensuite on a progressivement réduit la
précède présence jusqu'à finalement
décidé de partir donc le problème c'est
que le message n'a jamais été clair la
finalité de la présence américaine n'a
jamais été clair au départ la mission
c'était d'éradiquer al qaïda est de
faire en sorte que des groupes ne puisse
pas se servir de la via nice temps comme
un sanctuaire pour préparer des
opérations à l'étranger en réalité
aujourd'hui il ya une grande inconnue là
dessus puisque les talibans n'ont pour
le moment pas officiellement
coupé le coupé les ponts avec al qaïda
ils thrill traitant d' moi je suis allé
les rencontrer et j'aurais pose
évidemment la question de savoir s'il né
serait dans leur nouveau dans le nouveau
régime qui sont en train de mettre en
place si laisserai les groupes comme al
qaïda se déployer ils ne répondent pas
ils votent ils bottent en touche il
explique que par contre leur vision de
l'islam va s'imposer ils vont comment
imposer la charia là aussi c'est pareil
on ne sait pas exactement ce que ça
recoupe est-ce que ça recoupe de revenir
au traitement qui avait été aux
exécutions publiques aux pendaisons aux
mains coupées pour les valeurs est-ce
que ce type de comportement barbare et
archaïque vont avoir à nouveau pignon
sur rue en afghanistan et si toute la
question c'est la moitié des afghans
c'est à dire les afghanes qu'est ce que
va que vont devenir les afghanes elle
qui avait obtenu certains droits pendant
ses vingt ans de présence américaine la
toutoute cette question là elle elle est
sous jacente on ne sait pas exactement
quelle sera la politique des talibans et
puis il faut aussi regarder ce qu'ils
feront avec l'étranger quelle position
il choisira ils choisiront vont-ils
avoir une représentation à l'onu
vont-ils ou est-ce que ça va l'être un
pays interdit un pays fermé
tout ça est pour le moment une grande
inconnue oui vous le disiez vous
connaissez bien l'afghanistan vous y
avait passé trois semaines récemment
vous avez donc rencontré des talibans
vous avez également discuté avec la
population afghane comment perçois telle
cette intervention étrangère américaine
qui a duré 20 ans
la population afghane elle considère que
et nous quand on se présente comme
français ou qu'on soit français
américains ou anglais c'est la même
chose c'est-à-dire beaucoup de gens vous
disent vous regarde en blanc des yeux et
me dise vous avez détruit notre pays
voilà ça c'est quelque chose qui revient
de façon de façon assez récurrente les
talibans oui nous considèrent comme
faisant partie de cette coalition qui
est venu les envahir et qui a en effet
en 2001 provoqué la chute de leur régime
mais
aujourd'hui voilà il ya un énorme
ressentiment il ya la pression aussi
auprès de deux personnes qui se sont
beaucoup engagé d'être laissé sur place
j'ai rencontré les traducteurs qui ont
servi l'armée française
des personnes qui ont été et qui n'ont
pas pu avoir même si la france a quand
même accueilli en plus de 650
ressortissants afghans qui correspondait
aux professeurs ou aux gens qui étaient
voilà quelques années servit la présence
française en afghanistan il en reste un
certain nombre il restera très
certainement aussi des américains des
des afghans ayant servi les forces
américaines est là malgré les dires des
talibans qui assure qu' ils ne
toucheront pas à ces gens là que ces
gens là même si l'on voit là ça c'est le
discours officiel des talibans le
discours officiel des talibans et un
discours de séduction des populations et
un discours qui vise à rassurer
maintenant une fois au pouvoir est ce
que on va pas voir finalement des
espèces de purge parce que il faut
imaginer que l'afghanistan c est pas
simplement 20 ans de guerre ses quarante
deux en guerre permanente cdd génération
qui ne savent pas ce qu'est la paix et
voilà et donc
cesser miei l'habitude de deux massacres
de liquidation et secrétaires etc
peuvent reprendre le dessus
la grande question pour se terminer
c'est vraiment est ce que les taliban
nouveaux sont différentes des anciens
talibans et personne n'a la réponse pour
le moment alors on vous parliez tout à
l'heure de négociation qui était
finalement un peu biaisé puisque on sait
que les talibans contrôlent depuis
quelques mois l'essentiel du pays alors
qu'elles étaient donc l'or l'hormone et
d'essence pendant ces négociations
manifestement au palais présidentiel
les négociations qui ont eu lieu douar
où il y en a eu à téhéran récemment les
talibans n'ont cédé sur rien le
gouvernement a proposé plusieurs fois
des gouvernements d'union nationale
récemment ils ont proposé de partager le
pouvoir il n'y a eu aucune concession de
la part des taliban les talibans veulent
une victoire militaire alors c'est
important évidemment pour re pour
imposer le régime qui suit mais il faut
aussi le comprendre dans le cadre de la
nébuleuse jihadiste international les
talibans vont créer leur émirat savez un
émirat islamique
ils vont donc évidemment ils ont rayonné
auprès d'autres groupes comme death ou
comme al qaïda évidemment les talibans
ayant vaincu les américains ça leur
donne un titre et ça c'est très
important pour eux dans la galaxie de
cet islam radical ce qu'ils feront de
cette victoire est encore le widi et je
me répète très incertain est très
difficile à savoir quel va être
l'orientation du pays quel va être son
attitude aussi avec ses voisins
voilà donc on peut imaginer qu'ils les
talibans mais ils ont passé tous eu
d'effort là pour se faire renverser dans
un mois donc niveau on va essayer de
durée on va voir un peu comment ils vont
réagir alors et si les talibans ont
réussi à séduire jeudi véhémence par
tient de la population afghane c'est
parce que l'intervention américaine leur
a permis de passer un peu pour des
libérateurs finalement oui alors que moi
je non je ne pense pas que ce soit une
meuf partie de la population afghane
je ne peux pas évaluer combien de
personnes sont sympathisants des
talibans mais beaucoup par exemple il ya
une nouveauté par rapport à 2001 par
rapport à 96 au moment où ils ont pris
le pouvoir les talibans à l'époque était
essentiellement d'origine pachtoune
c'était le fond voilà le fond ethnique
du mouvement taliban le mouvement taleb
venait de 2,2 net et ashton qui fait 45
50 % de la population quelque fois ci
ils ont conquis le nord et ils ont
continué nord c'est-à-dire là où il ya
les tadjik les ouzbeks les hasards a
alors il n'y a pas eu beaucoup d'arabes
qui ont rejoint le camp des talibans
mais il ya eu un certain nombre de tadic
un certain nombre d'ouzbeks également et
salsa les a aidés dans leurs campagnes
fulgurante où ils ont pris d'abord le
nord du pays la dernière fois en 96 il
avait pris le site vers leurs zones
traditionnelles il ça veut dire qu'ils
ont été capables de séduire parmi des
populations qui ne l'étaient pas acquise
et parmi des populations qu'ils auront
fait la guerre aussi à l'époque via
décès des seigneurs de guerre comme
abdul rashid dostum ou vous même le
commandant massoud donc aujourd'hui les
talibans ont une vraie vraie assise dans
la population d'ailleurs si l'on ferait
vous rappeliez au début du reportage que
ils ont d'abord conquis les campagnes
mais si vous vous je mange le mouvement
qu'ils ont fait était très très faim
c'est à dire ils ont conquis les
districts effectivement autour des
villes et ils ont encerclé des villes
progressivement qui sont toutes tombées
comme des fruits mûrs par la reddition
ils ont utilisé parfois le conseil les
conseils d'anciens ce qu'on appelle des
barbes blanches c'est à dire ceux qui
ont une assise sur la population les
ancêtres pour aller négocier les
redditions de de l'armée afghane qui se
sont fait 120 échange de faim donc c'est
voilà la tête 18 mise en place est assez
remarquable la rapidité d'exécution a
été incroyable à partir du moment où ils
ont commencé à reprendre les capitales
régionales ils ont tous grignoter
jusqu'à kaboul là qui est en train de
tomber et puis il ya l'attitude du
gouvernement qui peut susciter des
interrogations il aurait pu crier au
coup d'état une fois que les talibans
sont arrivés dont kaboul au lieu de cela
il parle d'un transfert de pouvoir d'un
gouvernement de transition est ce que ça
vous étonne non mais vous savez le
gouvernement afghan le problème c'est
que c'est le reflet d'une problématique
afghane qui s'appelle la corruption qui
est endémique dans ce pays depuis
extrêmement longtemps j'appelle je vous
donnais simplement un chiffre 20 % du
pib afghan est issu de la drogue donc
rien que ça ça en dit long sur tout les
pots-de-vin tous les bakchichs qui
peuvent exister lors la société ne
serait ce que pour simplement le trafic
de drogue mais pour tout le reste tous
tout fonctionnaire on aime bien distant
et corrompu et face à ça mais vous avez
quoi vous allez des talibans qui sont
les zones qu'ils administrent mettant un
maître un savoir faire incroyable pour
savoir justement on reste deux des
afghans que eux ne sont pas corrompus
que eux pratiquent la loi d'allah donc
qu'une loi pure et qui apparaît qu en
tout pour une bonne majorité d'allemands
et notamment dans les zones rurales
comme relativement juste la justice
administré par kaboul elles étaient
délivrés dont elle m'était des mois à
s'exercer les tribunaux de la charia moi
j'ai assisté à comment une audience d'un
tribunal de la charia deux personnes
viennent pour une dispute au sujet d'un
chantent ils repartent la décision est
prise et en plus ils ont l'impression
que cette loi est injuste puisqu'elle
vient de liens d'allah le tout-puissant
donc si vous voulez ça correspond très
bien au mode extrêmement traditionnel
argon chez ces talibans y avait une voix
ce qui m'a vraiment surpris c'est
d'abord bon leur jeunesse leur fougue
leur certitude en leur victoire ils ont
un peu fait penser au cumin rouge dans
ce sens d'un groupe émanant des
campagnes avec une volonté d'imposer une
vision traditionnelle et ça
malheureusement les carouges donc c'est
le comment de sainte hermine et je ne
pense pas que les talibans iront jusqu à
perpétrer des massacres de grande
ampleur mais on ne sait pas en fait en
tout cas ils sont vraiment déterminés
c'est la seule force un peu cohérente
dans le pays le reste vous parler de ce
gouvernement mais on pourrait parler de
son art mais complètement fractionné à
vaux sur les grandes lignes de fractures
de la société afghane entre les tribus
entre les différentes ethnies et qui a
été incapable de ceux de se battre est
incapable de défendre son pays parce que
dans le fond elle n'existait pas elle
n'avait pas la volonté de le faire
régis le sommier merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions êtes grand reporter je
rappelle que vous venez de rentrer d'un
séjour en afghanistan trois semaines
exactement
merci à vous en tout cas d'avoir répondu
à nos questions et d'avoir est en direct
sur rtl france leur fille